- [Paige] Hello, grammarians.
Hello, David.
- [David] Hello. . . Paige.
- [Paige] (chuckles) So
in this video we're gonna
talk about a piece of
punctuation called the ellipsis
or ellipses in the plural
form as we have here.
So, what is an ellipsis?
- [David] So an ellipsis
is a punctuation mark
that is actually made up of
three periods with spaces
in between them, boop, boop, boop.
And it has two main uses.
- [Paige] Okay.
- [David] Use number one.
It indicates a pause in speech.
So like when you said, "Hello, David."
And I said, "Hello...Paige."
- [Paige] Right, so
that ellipsis in the middle
shows that you're pausing
when you're speaking.
So like, there's a lot of
reasons why you might pause
in your speech, you might
be hesitating or thinking
or just whatever the case may be,
you can use an ellipsis to
show that you're pausing.
- [David] Right.
Uh, and usage number two for the ellipsis
is that it shows that a portion
of quoted material has been taken out.
- [Paige] Why would you
take some of a quote out?
- [David] So we have here, Paige,
you have chosen a quote from
the renowned wizard and orator,
Albus Dumbledore, and he says, "Words are,
"in my not so humble opinion,
"our most inexhaustible source of magic."
If you wanted, you could
kind of take out that aside,
that, "in my not so humble opinion."
- [Paige] Yeah, I
don't have a lot of space
on this screen, so I don't
want to write that whole thing.
- [David] Mm-hmm.
- [Paige] Right.
So I can say, "Words are,
ellipsis, our most inexhaustible
"source of magic."
- [David] So, okay, so
Paige, I have a question.
- [Paige] Yeah.
- [David] Why do we even need this?
Why can't you just say,
"Words are our most
"inexhaustible source of magic"?
- [Paige] That's a great question.
So, if I quote someone and
I just sort of willy-nilly
take words out without
indicating that I've taken
some information out of the quote,
I can make it seem like someone said
something totally different
to what they actually said, right?
It can be so easy to misconstrue
someone's actual words.
So this shows that this isn't exactly
what Albus Dumbledore
said, but it's the point
that I want to get across with my quote.
Does that make sense?
- [David] I think so.
So you're saying that there's kind of like
an ethics question here.
- [Paige] Right.
- [David] So how do we
like accurately reproduce
someone's words without
misrepresenting them?
- [Paige] Totally.
- [David] So it shows
that you have messed
with it somehow.
- [Paige] Yes, exactly.
- [David] But that
you're calling out the fact
that you've cut out pieces, so
that people don't necessarily
get the wrong idea.
- [Paige] Totally.
- [David] But I think
there is kind of an art
to using ellipsis, right?
- [Paige] Yeah, I agree.
You know, you could use it in, you know,
technically wherever you want
when you're quoting someone
if you wanna take something out.
But if you use it over and
over or in the wrong places,
you can still misrepresent
what a person was saying.
- [David] If you wanted to,
you could render that sentence,
"Words are my opinion."
- [Paige] Yeah.
- [David] Right.
- [David] If you didn't use ellipses,
you could just render
that however you please,
because those were words that were said
approximately in that order, right.
- [Paige] Yeah, without ellipses or--
- [David] Without ellipses.
- [Paige] Okay.
- [David] You know,
you could just be like,
"Words are my opinion."
- [Paige] Mm-hmm.
- [David] And that's
not, that's not exactly
what Dumbledore said, right?
- [Paige] Right.
No, that's not what he was saying at all.
Those are some of the words he said,
but that's not the idea he
was trying to get across.
- [David] So you
have this responsibility
with ellipses to do the right thing,
to really represent the way
that somebody speaks accurately.
- [Paige] Yeah, definitely.
- [David] Let's talk about the end
of someone's sentence
and I want to indicate
that at some point after I cut
off the end of the sentence,
the sentence ends.
Where do I put that extra period
or do I need an extra period?
- [Paige] Right.
Okay.
- [David] So let's say our
sentence is something like,
"I like cheese, although I'm more partial
"to a Wensleydale than I am
to a cheddar or a Stilton."
You might want to just be able
to write that sentence as,
I like cheese, ellipsis, period, right?
- [Paige] Yeah.
- [David] So we're still including
the terminal punctuation in this sentence.
- [Paige] Yes.
- [David] To show that
it ends after the ellipsis.
- [Paige] Right, yeah.
That ellipsis there is showing
that stuff has been removed,
right, from this quote,
and then that final period
is showing that it's
the end of a sentence,
just like it normally does.
'Cause like, the ellipsis, you know,
looks just like three periods,
but it is it's own thing,
and doesn't stand in as a period.
- [David] So that's what,
so if we didn't have that final period,
it would just sort of look
like you were trailing off
like there was a pause.
I like cheese.
- [Paige] Yeah, there would
be no end to that sentence.
- [David] Right.
But those are the two functions
of ellipses, then, is that it
indicates a pause in speech,
like, "Hello...Paige."
Or it shows that a
portion of quoted material
has been taken out.
- [Paige] Yeah.
- [David] Like, "Words are...our most
"inexhaustible source of magic."
- [Paige] That was a
great Dumbledore impression.
- [Albus] Thank you, Paige.
You can learn anything.
- [Paige] Okay.
- [Albus] Albus out.
- [Paige] Paige out.
- [David] Cool.